welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and on the book of boba fett from
the desert comes a stranger cad bane a
bounty hunter from clone wars bad batch
to comics and now perhaps the most
chilling badass to strut into star wars
live action in years whether you have
watched all the animated episodes he has
shown up in or you might just be doing
some last minute brushing up to sound
like an expert to your friends no
judgment there are questions no one yet
knows the answers to about this guy
except me because i'm a self-described
genius who's never wrong
i'm gonna explain the full history you
need to know about cat bane why he is so
important and really regardless of how
much an expert you are on him all of our
questions really start with this one
line that he sneered at cobb then boba
fett
is a cold-blooded killer who worked with
the empire someone's here to make
friends yeah this from the same killer
who just said i'd be careful where i was
sticking my nose if i were you this pot
is calling the kettle noseless cad
bane's disgust with working with the
empire is the most fascinating takeaway
here because like boba fett fenix shan
black chrysanthe every bounty hunter he
too has a rich history of dealing with
multiple sides whoever pays the best
regardless of the alderaanian blood on
their hands was cad bane just plain to a
desert town on an outer rim planet known
for its recent anti-imperial sentiment
and the way they cheer like the bar
reaction meme when the second death star
exploded
[Applause]
or could something new have happened to
cad bane in these intervening years that
we have not yet seen a new chapter of
his backstory that we may see in the
finale episode or since all these shows
aren't blending together really any of
these grogu inference spin-off seasons
hey by the way if you want to hear me
talk about this stuff live new rockstars
is doing a live show in chicago february
11th 8pm talia hall ticket info is in
description it is so exciting to be at a
place where new rockstars can do this
kind of thing and if you come you may
get a chance to get some free new
rockstars merch like the shirt i'm
wearing otherwise you can go on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com and get yourself
one of these this exclusive boba fett
hunter design and if you get this you
will get the bonus option of writing a
custom shout out that will appear in our
star wars after shows okay cad bane cad
mane is a duros race and dave filoni
initially based him on lee van cleef's
angel eyes from the good the bad and the
ugly thus the irony of giving him these
fiery demonic eyes he's voiced by corey
burton both in animation and now in live
action burton being a longtime disney
voiceover artist he is equipped with
ll-30 pistols weaponized van braces
hover boots and these breathing tubes
that connect from his back into his
lungs and it's not because he needs
these to breathe normally in different
atmospheres this is really a measure to
prevent him from getting force choked
like mandalorian armor and gadgets and
gizmos this guy has an experience
getting entangled with jedi warriors and
knows how to handle himself around him
cadbane's relationship with boba fett
actually comes from an unfinished arc in
clone wars sixth season when he was
going to team up with the young boba
fett after the death of jango fett who
is cad bane's colleague back in the day
the cad would have ended an insurrection
by boba fett would have ended in a duel
between the two that dented boba's
helmet that dent is still visible
throughout these episodes of the book of
effect prominent from the very first
episode so i assume this duel will be
confirmed as part of their canonical
backstory and may be restaged in the
final episode but cadiban was first
introduced all the way back in 2009
season 1 episode 22 of clone wars part
of a multi-episode arc that
chronologically later picks up in season
three when cad bane took hostage of
senators on coruscant in order to free
zero the hut i got business with the
senate
how about you from a step aside on your
knees raise your hands
slowly son
i wouldn't be so hasty if i were you
during this arc cad's droid gang
actually kidnapped c-3po for scans of
the senate building that he ends up
delivering to jabba the hutt on tatooine
who tells him to freeze zero the hut so
that zero can't give the republic dirt
against the other huts and then kad
takes zero to the hutt home world of now
huda and then ends up in a conflict with
a jedi offers a deal to them to deliver
zero back to them but he ends up
escaping thanks to his trusty techno
service droid toto 360. maybe we'll get
to see this guy in live action too or
maybe not hold that thought thanks to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-proportioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
door they make home cooking easy fun and
affordable that's why it's america's
number one meal kit this valentine's day
skip the crowded restaurants and eat at
home with a delicious three-course meal
featuring a starter scrumptious sides
and a decadent dessert hello fresh has
more five star reviews than any other
meal kit because the food is delicious
here's a little hello fresh hack
increase your box serving so the same
amount of cooking will leave you with
some leftovers to impress that special
someone for lunch the next day hello
precious pre-proportioned ingredients
mean there's less prep for you and less
wasted food i recently cooked up a hella
fresh meal so savory all the taste buds
were activated it was super easy not too
much cleanup i didn't even have to think
about it so go to hellofresh.com and use
the code rockstars 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts cad bane
returned in a clone wars season 2 arc in
which he worked with darth sidious to
track down force sensitive children
insidious plot to create an army of sith
spies to overwhelm the jedi this guy
kidnaps babies out of their cribs cat
bane also returning to season 4 are
joining separatists to try to
assassinate chancellor palpatine if only
he was allowed to finish the job in 2017
cad bane actually came back briefly in
the darth maul comics in an arc that was
set all the way back before phantom
menace a plot to kidnap the jedi padawan
el dragus doesn't matter how old or
young this guy is gonna snatch your kids
bringing us to last year on the bad
batch catbane kidnaps omega for the
kaminoans after beating hunter in a duel
in episode 8. every time this guy comes
back he always introduces himself with
the brim of his hat lowered then in
episode 9 of bad batch fenix shan
intercepts them
hello payne you got no business messing
with my score you of all people know
it's all about the price they fight and
finnick messes them up pretty good
allowing omega to escape and end up back
with the bad batch now we should
acknowledge that the reason cadbane was
initially hired by camino and the reason
they wanted omega back was that she was
actually a very valuable genetically
altered jango fett clone making her a
kind of cloned sister to boba fett so
with cad bane now on tatooine facing a
conflict with boba fett and fenix shand
it's very possible that this whole
history with omega boba fett's clone
sister could come up and we might
actually see a live action cameo of
omega who like boba fett does have a
thing for riding rancors now the arrival
of cad bane in live action could simply
mean a reunion of these characters or
the return of other famous bounty
hunters like bosk but this episode
placed so much emphasis on cad seething
rage he's an older wearier gunslinger
like clint eastwood and unforgiven like
he's got a personal score to settle he
says tatooine belongs to the syndicate
as long as the spice keeps running
everyone will be left alone now it looks
like the pike syndicate is the authority
that takes over right after the empire
collapses in fact in episode three the
pikes wear this new sigil that was not
in the animated series it looks like it
is at least inspired by the image of the
death star exploding so it makes sense
that cadbane is now with this empire
hate and pike syndicate now of course
there are all kinds of reasons to hate
the empire they were all about genocide
but i wonder if cad bane might have
personally suffered or witnessed a more
recent imperial war crime like the night
of a thousand tears we just saw on
mandalore or palpatine's scorched earth
contingency plan of operation cinder
something that could have taken from him
his beloved toto his little dried too we
also saw the close-up of his boots looks
like he might no longer have his hover
boots perhaps because he might have had
to burn those escaping some fiery
disaster or perhaps between his
experience with sidious and his later
gig with kevin owens might have helped
him connect the dots to whatever secret
cloning plot sidious is still part of in
the shadows of this universe that makes
cad bane's lingering anti-imperial
saltiness especially fresh cad bane's
anti-empire line is just one little
wrinkle among many that now stretch his
withered face suggesting there is more
complexity to this character that they
plan to explore so pop this guy in the
back to tank because we got some inner
scars to heal you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
you